lange war sie die sängerin annoni ein er
über 30 jahre lang 30 jahre leben im
falschen körper 30 jahre kampf um
anerkennung
und jetzt
das erste solo-album unter weiblichem
namen und eine einzelausstellung in
bielefeld unter dem titel my cruze meine
wahrheit
was ist ihre wahrheit
das ist eine lange geschichte
es ist eine ansammlung von dingen die
mich geprägt haben die mich zu dem
machen was ich bin was man isst diese
scheinbar einfache wahrheit
man ahnt es das ist bei einer
transgender künstlerin eine lange
geschichte
juni teilt sie seit den 90ern mit der
öffentlichkeit wie hier mit früheren
super 8 aufnahmen der junge enten in new
york man spürt es schon hier
das drängende den ausbruch
kennys
lou reed holt anthony auf die große
bühne besingt mit ihm kann die darin die
transgender muse von andy warhol
von da an feiert in die musikszene für
seine hoch pathetischen leidtragenden
poppt rahmen
mühlacker
für diese stimme die das wahre leben im
falschen beklagt die einsamkeit den tod
immer mehr verweigert internet die
körperliche präsenz erhöht sich bei live
auftritten
das neue album ist noch radikaler annoni
tritt zurück lässt naomi campell die
lippen zu ihrem song bewegen ein protest
gegen krieg und zerstörung
der protest geht nach außen blendete
nomis eigene identität aus auch die
kunst hilft dir dabei kunst zu schaffen
ist so anders als musik zu machen
mein körper steht nicht mehr unter
beobachtung
ich kann mich ausdrücken und die
menschen können das erforschen
aber das ist nicht mehr teil meines
körpers eines gesichts eines fleisches
mit ihrer kunst braucht der besucher ein
in den unis biografie
erfährt mehr über ihre einflüsse wie
durch den fotografen peter roger den
chronisten der new yorker subkultur in
den 70ern
sein berühmtestes bild candy darling auf
dem sterbebett fotografiert
in dieser ausstellung erfährt man ein
ganzes leben
moniz leben und was es bedeuten kann die
eigene wahrheit zu erzählen
wieviel mutes für all das braucht sie
angst verletzt zu werden
nein haben sie natürlich habe ich angst
aber das ist nicht die frage
wir werden alle geboren und müssen alle
sterben
wir müssen in unserem leben danach
streben das maximum an erfüllung zu
erreichen und wir dürfen uns nicht davor
fürchten